[Music]
let's go to lawrence
in philadelphia what's up brother
lawrence
uh hey doc how you doing i'm good my man
how are you
well have kind of a rough season going
on right now yeah appreciate you uh
taking your time to speak with me oh you
got it anytime so what's up my brother
so i'm a single dad and i've had uh both
kids essentially full time since october
of 2018. my uh
my daughter turns nine on saturday and
my son is 11.
my son
is
starting to become somewhat of an issue
from a behavioral standpoint he
is struggling with life right now he's
full of tons of anxiety and frustration
due to his mom essentially no longer
playing any sort of active role in his
life which i completely understand where
is mom
mom is currently in
a mental health facility outside of
philadelphia yikes man how long was it
degenerative how long was that going on
well you know she
she
when i met her i knew that she was
regularly taking opioids because she was
in a car accident in college when a tree
fell on her car and she suffered from
chronic migraines back in the early
2000s what the best neurologist would do
is they would just toss a whole bunch of
narcotics at you that's right just just
to manage the pain and when you know the
effect of narcotics took off um at that
point in time they would switch the
dosage or the brand or whatever case it
was and unfortunately she became hooked
i don't blame her for that
it's unfortunate and
you know i i was somewhat ignorant to
what narcotics could do to someone
because back when you and i are growing
up john they didn't really
refer to any type of opioid pandemic and
i just didn't know what the symptoms of
addiction were with respect to something
that brilliant doctors prescribed and
was readily available at pharmacies
that's right um i'm so sorry that's that
that i've i've seen that up close
that'll take your take everything i'm so
sorry man
yeah it's it's it's it's unfortunate you
know it ultimately changed everything
in our lives it tore our family apart
there was uh
there were certain things that went on
which just forced me to unfortunately
file for divorce which i never saw
myself doing but here we are
other things started happening at which
point
got my lure involved and we filed for
uh residential custody and they've been
living with me ever since and
since august of 2021 they've seen her in
person like an hour and a half
was she in was she institutionalized
when they saw her
no she wasn't
she wasn't she was living with
their sister's father at the time they
have a sister that's going to be three
they've seen her maybe a handful of
times
since she's been born because of
issues with her mother yeah um it's it's
just it's really frustrating and it's
you know it's it's a lot of things it's
a lot on me but
you know i'm doing my best just to give
the kids as regular of a life as
possible under their circumstances so um
first thing do this for me okay take as
deep breath as you possibly can and hold
it for a second
hold it
no you let it out it's cheater i did
take it
you can edit this out nope we're leaving
it in
hold it
all right let it out
and then i want you to drop your
shoulders down as hard as you can pull
them down okay
sure i can feel you talking about this
and starting to speed up your cadence
because this is still really this is
you're it's just not as though this is a
healing wound this is a this thing's
still bleeding right the cut's still
happening right
it's daily yeah all right um
did was she taken when she was pregnant
she she was we were had her monitor
monitored by um a different doctor that
essentially weaned her down to a smaller
dose but she was still taking
during with pregnancies um did your kid
either one of your kids or your son
especially
was he diagnosed with nals
neonatal opioid withdrawal syndrome
he wasn't diagnosed with it shortly
after he was born he was put in the nicu
just for monitoring um they were worried
about that they didn't do any of that
with my daughter
okay all right so she your wife wasn't
on methadone or any other
she was telling me i don't know okay so
they just were just cutting her does
okay
um
all right so i wanna be real careful
about something and hopefully this gives
you some peace even though it's gonna
feel like it's gonna make things more
chaotic okay
i want you to do your best you can from
this point forward for the rest of your
kid's life
of not saying because of or due to
okay
um earlier on when you're talking about
your son's anxiety he's got this anxiety
because he is
because he can't see mom
he probably has that anxiety for a whole
cocktail of reasons okay
and whenever we dump
we distill it down to a single single
problematic data point we try to solve
that data point and it never makes the
whole thing better and so i want to look
at the whole ecosystem that's going on
here okay
um there are a and you probably know
these but this is just for the audience
as much as it is for you
um the
longitudinal neurodevelopment literature
is all over the place and so one of the
first things i do is i take animal
models and i move them out and when you
do that there's just not a ton of stuff
out there um
some of them show um
opioid use in utero
effects of things like iq and language
development all that kind of stuff some
of them show no development no
difference some of them showed
difference for up until like four or
five months some of them show difference
in boys and girls almost all of them
universally um this is with methadone so
i think it's methadone maybe it's the
other one
um show some sort of increased risk for
anxiety for adhd and all that so
that's cool to know that
um here's where i think a lot of those
studies miss and it's i don't blame the
studies because they're just trying to
to set a baseline biochemically
but your kids have grown up in a world
of chaos is that right
unfortunately yep hey don't do that to
yourself okay it just is it's it is okay
let me give you that it is unfortunate
but i don't want you to take ownership
of the misfortune at this point okay
um they grew up with a mom as an addict
and for a kid you know this but that's
so
um disregulating to see a human in front
of you
and touch them but they're not really
there you know what i mean
luckily at the time they're so young
that i don't think they realize that
well i'm telling you their bodies for
sure did 1 000 did they absorbed it the
same disconnect you felt relationally
where you could be holding hands with
somebody that you knew was not there you
could sleep with somebody have sex with
somebody and they're not there
they pick that same thing up and it's
it's exponentially works worse because
they're have neuronal development going
on right then okay
and so what what i am most compelled by
is gabor mate and others who have looked
at
pre-maternal stress in utero stress in
moms creates this downstream of this
this cocktail that pulses through these
kids
and they end up with anxiety and all
sorts of cascaded things down the road
why do i tell you that
the thing that you can control right now
is the ecosystem
the peace
right and that's that is where i want
you to focus your energy on moving
forward
um so i just gave you a lot of
info and i didn't even let you ask your
question so what is your question
question
um the behavioral issues are starting to
be something beyond my control okay tell
me about it i'm starting to become
just
talking back hitting kids biting kids
like what are we talking about here he
yeah i mean he's been he's been
suspended a time or two due to physical
issues
um there was a time he
started you know throwing hands at a
sitter i've called the police on him on
occasion because i didn't want to
hurt him well restraining him and he was
just someone out of control
i in terms of discipline you know i i do
my
i have a hard time not yelling at times
just because there's there seems to be
nothing else to do
at that time i haven't write sentences
sentences was the latest thing i've been
doing uh in terms of discipline and he
absolutely hates that but lately when i
say right census he will just say no no
i'm not going to do that yeah and and
you know all this stuff combined the
issues at school
his therapist is saying we want to get
him psychoanalyzed his family crisis
counselor at school wants to get him
psychoanalyzed you know law enforcement
has spoken to him and they say you know
he definitely needs some type of
psychiatric evaluation and i'm just i'm
worried yeah
he's going to put on meds yeah because i
know what he did to his mom yeah
yeah
and your your
[Music]
fears is um valid okay
let me talk let me talk to you about a
couple of of things until we get to the
psychoanalytic part okay
or the psychoanalysis psychoanalytics
um
so i want you to start thinking about
that body that little boy's body how old
is he you said
he's 11 11 okay fifth grade fifth grade
so you have a little boy whose body is
being overwhelmed by
the sensations and feelings and that
comes out with behaviors that in adults
are criminal acts
and in children it's simply symptomatic
of a body that is
think of a cup underneath a faucet it's
just overflowing okay
and throwing hands
punching swinging yelling just that
caustic screaming is a body that's
dysregulated and this is going to sound
counterintuitive but that's a body
screaming for connection in a in a
backwards chaotic way
and so it's a body screaming for
boundaries in a chaotic way and
yet there's a disregulation for when you
put boundaries down now he's like no i'm
not doing that and so i want you to
begin to think of punishment not as a
way to force him to do things he doesn't
like or uncomfortable with him
can would you be willing to flip the
whole paradigm around for me
i'm going to try anything though okay i
want you just to try this for 30 days
and if it's a bust write me back and i
promise i'll read the email aloud um on
the show that i've i failed you okay
okay
um here's what i want you to do
uh well let me ask you one question have
you ever sat down with him and just
talked about mom how heartbroke breaking
it is for everybody
yes they are very difficult
conversations how do they how do they go
i mean
as of late it's trying to understand
it's trying to tell him why he can't see
mom currently
you know to try to express why there's
mom's mind is sick
um
you know every time he sees him she
looks normal and you know her voice
sounds normal
having a kid comprehending that their
brain is sick and making them do things
or not do the things that they should be
doing that's that's very difficult
concept
and then nothing like there's no way for
him even to talk to her that's a hard
thing you know
if we've done the thing you know it's
almost like you know she's dead it's the
same thing yes except she's not and
that's the problem there's no closure
right no no it's just she's not there
and you know he has a hard time thinking
you know well daddy you know you did
this where he keep me from mommy so i
have him call
my ex his mom you know she'll confirm
everything you know i keep telling him
how much i love him yeah okay so i want
you to this is not at this point about
data this is about his body okay
and so what we're gonna do is we're
gonna address the body here here's a
couple ways we're gonna do that
number one
we're going to if you don't already
invite him into this don't force him the
whole world's been forced upon him okay
so i want you to invite him in
to
and again i got a 12 year old and i know
this is awkward okay
and even my son's like dad and just tell
him
this one's for your old man even though
i know it's for him
is a
20 to 30 second hug a couple of times a
day maybe right before school and after
school and say we're going to do hug
time and he may go dude i'm doing that
see if you can get him to buy into that
okay and your daughter too
cool
the second thing is i want you to find
ways
highly intentionally intentional ways
not accidental ways to put your hand on
his skin
preferably on his face or on the back of
his neck okay
and when you're hugging him i want you
to put one hand on the back of his neck
and hold that area
20 to 30 seconds two or three times a
day okay there's a ton of bioregulatory
sensory stuff that happens skin to skin
trans transmission and it's gonna bring
his heart rate down it's gonna bring his
body down okay and all we're trying to
do is teach him what it feels like to
not be spun up
and we're going to teach him that in the
presence of dad and in the presence of
relationship is where you find that
spinning slow down
and right now everything about
relationships spins that sucker up you
see what i'm saying
these are quiet teaching moments that
i'm stunned or not in every psychiatric
office in the world
um i would even go as far to say
something as silly as
um
oh man
um
some sort of hey let me massage your
fingers
let me like we hold a lot of tension in
our hands a lot of tension in our feet
um
with little children little little kids
who have been abused one of the things
that a a therapist might do is take a
lotion and just rub feet because all
we're doing is teaching the body how to
be touched and how to
okay so that's number one number two
have you all done any sort of letter
writing to mom
no i tried to get him to write in a
journal just to capture his thoughts and
he just he's even hesitant to doing that
okay
um two things to do there number one um
get a journal that is between you two
and tell them hey this is two secret
guys just for two dudes
and you write to him and leave it on his
bed
and all he he has to bring it back and
put it on your bed hopefully it's got
one line in it
and in that journal i want you to do
age-appropriate stuff
but let him know that you miss mom let
him know that today was a hard day or
today was a good day or today i actually
cried and what we're teaching him is
dad's not crazy and he's not crazy
and so his feelings start to look like
that because right now you look like a
big strong tough
got it all together guy and we want to
teach him no here's what's going on in
dad's heart and he can read it over and
over and over again okay and hopefully
he begins to share with you i've heard
parents write me back and say my kid
just wrote today was good
and if they start weeping with they
didn't they've never had that level of
connection okay um another one is write
letters to mom and it'd be cool if you
all did this together
and his letters may be short and you can
tell them you can be really angry you
can be really sad i want you to tell her
about what happened today
but we're going to write these things
and we're going to put them in an
envelope and you are not going to mail
them
okay
but this is an exercise and you can
commit to doing it too
sure
we're teaching him here's where those
feelings that are burning holes in us
here's where they go here's a good place
to do that is to write it down okay
and then
here's the last one and then we'll get
to the medication stuff the last one is
i want you to create with him and your
daughter
i know this has been a mess i know this
is all hard i miss mommy y'all miss
mommy but here's the world we're in
right now mommy's in the hospital and
she's not okay right now and so we need
to create some rules for our house and
you've probably heard me talk about this
on the show multiple times it works
really well here and what we're doing is
we're going to go to like michael's
we're going to go to a hardware store
and get a big piece of board or whatever
we're going to doll it up and make it
nice
and we're going to write the lawrence
let's say your last name smith the smith
family rules this is who the smiths are
and they're less rules but they're more
value so let's call it that the smith
values
and i want your kids especially your son
but your daughter to for them to have
input on this
who are we and i want you all to make it
a fun exercise get ice cream and
whatever their favorite food is make it
a fun thing where y'all are writing
things down and then you're gonna paint
it on this board and you're gonna hang
it up in the living room even if it
doesn't match
here's where we're getting at
when your son hits somebody
you do you are not punishing him
he is choosing to go meet with the
police
and what we're slowly going to do is
teach him
that he has a choice in how his day goes
not that he's gonna do something that
will
that will
cut off relationship because right now
he knows he can push you far enough
that his punishment is disassociation
with dad
that you will use your relationship with
him as a weapon
you did this you have to go out here i'm
casting you away from me
and when i want to flip that on its head
and i want him to understand that when i
do this i'm choosing to leave dad and i
don't like to do that
because right now he's trying to see
how far i can push you before you're
going to go to
how far can i push my teacher for she
disappears on me like mom did
and what we want to do is teach him
any disappearing is going to be a choice
that you're making and dude it breaks
this is how i tell my kids these are my
exact words
it breaks my heart that
i'm choosing to have my heart broken
right now
you chose to leave the room for 30
minutes or for an hour or to not go
fishing with us
i'm choosing to be sad about that
because i only like fishing when you're
with me
and you just chose to do xyz not study
for this test to not whatever
and you chose to not go and i can't
stand that please don't make that choice
ever again because i don't like fishing
without you
you see our flip and now i'm telling you
it's a light switch night and day in my
home okay because they feel the strong
sense of ownership about it now like all
of us sometimes it's like
yeah it's worth it i'm gonna drive 70
over the speed limit if i get caught i
get caught right but most of the time
i'm watching this thing shift okay now
let's get to the meds
i do believe that your kid is in in line
for some sort of psycho eval
okay sure
as a parent i cannot speak to as a
psychiatrist so i'm just gonna tell you
you and i are hanging out on uh grabbing
a drink and you and i just met and we're
just hanging out okay this is what i
would tell you
about what i would do with my kids
um
i feel hyper
strong about benzodiazepines
as a no-no okay i have it written into
my psychiatric power of attorney that if
i get institutionalized they still can't
give me those drugs i'd rather be
institutionalized than be on those drugs
and not into the world okay
so i have a very strong
um and that's off of anna limkey's work
and any number of psychiatrists who are
now beginning to write more and more
about this ongoing benzo crisis that we
got
i will also say that there are some
ssris that are
magic
for dealing with anxiety
there are do you mind just elaborating
what the depends on myopian and ssri are
it's a selective serotonin reuptake
inhibitor right so
there are two different medications that
have two different brain chemistry
pathways
um one basically keeps the it's just the
way that the synapses the neurons talk
to each other across synapse and ssris
are going to be traditional stuff like
prozac right and it simply keeps more
stuff hanging around benzos are the
xanaxes of the world and it's a it's a
rabbit hole okay
and so
i have i would have no problem
if i sat down with somebody and they
said all right we've done all the stuff
your son um
at this point he's so disregulated his
alarm system is so sensitive right now
like dude you've been in a you've been
in a hotel where you have you're
steaming up the shower you know
and
it sets off the fire alarm the smoke
alarm that's just an attitude
it's a it's a it's a dysfunctional alarm
system your 11 year old may be there and
that's okay
um
what an ssri is going to do it's going
to help turn that alarm down a little
bit it will not solve the problem but
what it will allow him to do is to then
go sit with a counselor
to then begin to regulate some of these
um behaviors that you and i was talking
about a minute ago
and
be very open with the doctors about
mom's
opioid addiction
about the prenatal use of opioids
and your concerns about addictive
behaviors and any good psychiatrist will
walk alongside you in that journey tell
them that you want to try any and all
behavioral interventions before you get
medication okay but i do think
a psycho evals is important right now
okay that doesn't mean they're gonna
take your kid from you and dope them up
for eternity you're still the parent
okay
now that's my concern if you sit with
the doctor and they say look
you talked to some nut job on a podcast
who said stay away from benzos we think
this is the best thing for you right now
you can say great i'm gonna go get a
second opinion and go get a second
opinion and tell that psychiatrist
exactly what happened i went in saying i
if if we have to do meds let's do ssris
they forced benzos do you agree with
that and dude they're the doctors and
i'm not
and so at some point you have to decide
i'm gonna go off into the woods and
treat this on my own or i'm gonna listen
to the doctors and i also know that
you've got a
um you got burned bad by them in the
past you lost the level of your life and
all she did was whatever the doctors
told her right
that's right that's right and so this is
a scary season right now so all i'm
telling you is how i would approach this
if these were my kids
i cannot give you medical advice and i
can't give you even therapeutic advice
because i don't have that sort of
relationship with you or your kid
but i'm just telling you what i would do
if it was my kid
ultimately i think your kid needs some
professional intervention and i also
absolutely understand your um
discomfort with that it's well earned
i'm just also worried that my daughter
might ultimately hit down the same path
i i think i think it i think there's a
every reason to believe that here's the
deal some kids respond by punching kids
other kids respond with straight a's
um often young young girls will exhibit
adhd and anxiety by getting really quiet
and following all the rules
and so we don't know what's going on
inside of them because we're just
looking for the demonstrative behaviors
they're gonna either violate to violate
whatever rules we have or they're gonna
cause uh further chaos and so yes i
would expect growing up in the home of
an addict with a mother who used um
while she was in utero and all of the
relational chaos and the divorce i would
expect there to be challenges with your
daughter as well that's why getting
upstream
with
dad connection with skin to skin contact
with hey
i'm teaching you what choice looks like
i'm teaching you with the gap between
stimulus and response looks like all of
those things are going to create a new
household and so going all the way back
to the very first thing i told you
we're not looking for well it's because
mom left because here's the natural
tendency is that i'm gonna find somebody
to replace mom and that's not how that
works
um what we need to do is we need to
change the entire air in that home
and let me tell you one last thing
you my friend have got to do some
healing work on your own is that fair
yes yeah
your son and i don't say this in a
shaming way i say this in an empowering
way
is absorbing your tension in chaos too
okay
and so one of the greatest gifts you
could give him is for you to go see
somebody and begin getting well yourself
is that fair
that is fair okay
um you will also set a give him a
picture of what a a grown man who's
going to get help looks like and that
would be one of the greatest gifts you
can give him one long term
okay
yes
so
please go see a psychiatrist or go see a
professional okay it's expensive to get
an eval very very expensive
um
and if you get a good one it can be
worth its weight in gold
and it will give a road map to you and
do not hesitate to speak up
and also um
don't hesitate to get a second opinion
if you're uncomfortable okay
okay is that fair
something's got to change
there you go
you know i don't want to lose my kids
that's right they're great little people
um
in the same if you will introduce the
the choice language that i was talking
about in your home
um instead of yelling and by the way
from this call on we're not yell anymore
cool
i've been working on that i know i know
but let's not work on it anymore let's
just say no more and here's what we're
gonna do
you're gonna introduce choice to your
kids very very soon
like this weekend probably and
when you're about to blow
i want you to look at your son or your
daughter and say i'm choosing to step
away for a minute
so that i can be in control of my body
and then i want you to step away for a
minute and go walk around the house
and then you come back and you're
teaching your son you're giving him a
picture of what
regulating your body looks like
regulating your emotions looks like what
then when that hurt and fire
come up
how to release it because those punches
he's throwing that's just his version of
you yelling
it's it's that that overrun of emotion
right and so i want you to lead the
charge in your home on showing what this
looks like and that also means you got
to get some counseling asap brother will
you do that
yes
i did a little bit but i i clearly have
work to do
i want you to go into a counselor and
say i want to heal and be well i don't
just want to talk endlessly for the next
nine months i want to learn to heal and
be well
okay and let's start there okay there's
gonna be a lot of action not a lot
there's gonna be some talking for sure
there's gonna be a lot of action a lot
of changing your behaviors okay i want
you to stay on the line i'm gonna send
you a copy of my new book own your past
change your future here's the deal
at some point you're going to sit down
and you're going to own what happened
your whole world blew up your wife got
sick and your whole world blew up
and then you have to be about what are
we going to do next okay so hang on the
line here we're going to send it to you
do you commit to going to see somebody
yourself and taking your kid to see
somebody i don't hear you say it
i'm gonna
heal myself to make my kids better nope
you're gonna heal yourself because
you're because you're worth being loved
my man
okay hey you didn't fail your wife dude
stop carrying that around
you did not fail her
i hear you the medical system did
she struggled a whole she and she
probably has a whole lineage you got to
set that down man this isn't on you you
didn't fail
did you drop pills in her drinks
clearly not okay well
some of the calls i get on the show
aren't so clear you didn't fail
so you're not going to get well for your
kids you're going to get well for you
because you deserve to get that to be
well
and by doing that
they're going to have a chance to be
well too
they're lucky to have you my man
and starting today everything is
different everything's different
um hang on the line here we're gonna
issue this stuff and if you would like
um we can clip this call for you raw and
send it to you so you don't have to wait
a month before this thing launches and
have some of that info so we'll see if
we can get that to you in the next
couple days